mama June considers a breast
augmentation and meets a new man meet
somebody the ice-cream shop really
[Music]
on this week's episode of from not too
hot mama June is gearing up for her skin
removal surgery in Los Angeles and
considering a boob job to go along with
her tummy tuck well I mean they're a
little droopy I've had four kids to help
her decide what size breasts she'll get
mama stuffs her bra and takes her bigger
chest out for a spin
you got new tits you want to show all
catching the eye of a potential new
suitor so they're getting whatever they
want on me how's this guys good and cool
for you cuz you don't have much time fun
a day for sugar is wedding
but things didn't go so well on their
date haven't kids you have none thought
it like right now you look like you lost
pound or two I would say since last I
saw you maybe more in the upper area I
would say I'm sure there's be a guy that
would love all this curves and sorry you
wasn't able to even touch it
guess we'll have to tune in next week to
see if mama goes through with the
surgery and whether or not she finds a
date to sugar bears wedding
[Music]
you